hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
no I'm John Humphrey Olivia Olivia
Mattia
with head yeah watch Game of Thrones
episode 4 of season 8 right now I'm
excited to get into this yeah welcome to
our new place it's all yellow before we
hop into this gonna make a couple of
mentions first off thank you to Eric
over at nerd product for editing this
video for us it's quite a task that he
has edit out a whole reaction to ten
minutes because of the fact that YouTube
only allows ten minutes worth of
reaction footage you guys who follow him
at nerd cronic he's also done work for
people like Eamon snow ah kasam work at
the Schmo down he has his own YouTube
channel and podcast you could find his
podcast forever podcasts are available
and lastly like I mentioned this will
just be reaction highlights in here
full-length TV reaction stream alongs
are all available over at our patreon
page over there even though we also do
weekly Q&A as we do TV show reaction
stream along for many shows that
includes my hero academia just picked up
attack on time and a good a little bit
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one
punch man John picked up Cobra Kai
season 2 he did all of haunting of Hill
House and supernatural and several of
those shows also have reaction eyelets
included that is one punch man Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood supernatural
this latest season of attack on Titan
and my hero academia recovery Game of
Thrones full length over there so we
really appreciate you guys to go ahead
show your support
cuz that's how we were able to pay air
to do
[Music]
Eric our editor you're editing this
right now
which you are
I think you should just keep the whole
opening and then try to figure out the
next six minutes of what to do
[Music]
I think you should be awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
what does she think it exactly done
Melvin I can't tell you this
[ __ ] here I can't tell her she's
like upset or she's likely Adele whether
or not he should take her
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I never happy there's no need
Oh Oh there you go oh yeah oh snap oh is
what Game of Thrones all about some
people get it on before the war and some
people but it'll become the game after
they've had sex she has after drink no
getting mad how many times you bend the
knee removed it what you swear what you
need is a non-disclosure agreement
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
then you're sucking grandsons what will
in a family with a [ __ ] weight
the men of my family don't do well in
the capital terrine
I have a seat
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know edit Murray doesn't even say
bye to ghosts
they made eye contact let's how badass
oh god damn so many people know
information I worry about her state of
mind
Oh to the Queen where does state of mind
[Laughter]
worry about it is I feel like this
episode we've gotten back to like the
Tyrion personality avid misses
holy [ __ ] what just happened
oh my god don't look oh my god no no the
bow holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] them up the nurse Oh God
that did not see that coming that's came
out of nowhere
oh wow Tyrion is Jack Sparrow in this
situation I want her to burn it down oh
[ __ ] perhaps it's good that people see
the Daenerys Stormborn made every effort
to avoid bloodshed and Cersei nervously
refused
we should meet him today oh boy he
doesn't want to show that's why he bent
the knee if you considered the best
ruler might be someone who doesn't want
to rule we're discussing treason I will
act in their interest no matter the
personal cost his work happens to her
you are so dead berries stay with me
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
Jesus Christ resides at a better prep
your Queens last dragon his father your
mom is a battle weary and depleted while
ladders have been reinforced with the
gun [ __ ] up
oh [ __ ]
Oh can't be over that's hard to
ourselves I know you don't care about
your people why should you
they hate you and you hate them
maybe so but that doesn't mean your life
has to end
oh there you say the right thing doesn't
mean no baby has to die
[Music]
hi
[Music]
Oh
raynelle team back we go mom
yeah if I could do it get in there
[Music]
[Music]
Oh next reasonabie [ __ ] crazy well
Game of Thrones another crowd-pleasing
100% satisfying episode for all fans
everywhere unanimous enjoyment after
watching this episode I can tell no one
is gonna get upset with the way this
unfolded am i right guys
am i right can't imagine that there's
anything in this episode man just me
Megan a sarcastic comment just like just
like screw this guy I like the way it
ended I was feeling very mad in a good
way like I was feeling Daenerys is anger
well man yeah you're gonna play yeah
like it like [ __ ] kill all those
innocent people just get in there murder
like I was getting into that that zone I
was getting so infuriated within the
realm of what the protagonists are
feeling towards the antagonist so that I
thought was incredibly effective there's
just a lot of stuff in between how it's
just like I mean just going through the
episode the celebration at the beginning
I thought was nice to have some moment I
mean of course we started off with
reminding us of the main characters who
did die from last week honoring their
deaths Jon Snow's delivery kind of has a
bit of a Captain Kirk cadence to it
something in the breath pattern that he
has ever a few words at a time very very
stoic and rousing when everyone's having
a fun time you're like I just know that
there's gonna be some serious tension
coming right now isn't there there's
gonna be some serious tension coming our
way I really liked Daenerys Miglia
Clarke's performance a lot in this
episode I thought she was so nuanced in
almost every single frame she had on
camera any time she was talking with
anyone you could feel there was like a
deeper layer of repressed anger
underneath almost every single scene she
had I even really liked the scene that
she has with John where she's begging
him to just not say [ __ ] to anyone cuz
she's like trust me things will get out
of hand it'll be bad that little turn
that she has when she when John says
like we can make it work and she says we
can and I just told you how everything
that would Daenerys I really did love a
lot it's funny to watch like Daenerys
you
really be on her side I really thought
she was on point to this entire episode
I felt her emotions I understood what
she was coming from and the entire
episode I was like why is no one
listening to her she's the only one that
I understand which is coming from that I
agree with the entire episode yeah I was
Tunde this entire up so weirdly put her
in a point of view where they made her
feel more of an underdogs nothing like a
hundred percent underdog which he was
certainly in an isolated situation
through a lot of this she's a stranger
in a very strange land yet even though
she's just done a very physical service
to them and still she notices we that
and they don't trust her and and they
are just all not familiar it's like even
at the party even when they're all just
trying to enjoy the victory everybody is
off with their own people yeah even if
they're not ungrateful there's certainly
a lack of appreciation that's not being
demonstrated or anything that went down
with her she's not one of them every
time they got a chance they were
whispering to each other how they didn't
trust her we're talking trash about her
every chance they got I think they're
ungrateful have had that opportunity if
Danny didn't bring her armies in her
dragon Jaime and Brienne I thought was a
really nice touch so we've got a [ __ ]
heartbreaker in the book I'm told pretty
gnarly how we get the episode we like
together Thor to it yes and then in the
same episode Jaime you dick why would
you do this from a psychological
standpoint I get it I do it's like I'm
I'm back and forth on that
psychologically I'm like yeah you're
kind of triggered you're going back to
your old ways I don't know how if that's
really gonna be the follow-through cuz
they kind of set it up where he's gonna
go maybe help out Cersei in some way cuz
everything he was saying was about no
matter what happens I'm there to get
back to Cersei I'm there to help her
that was his whole speech then he leaves
he abandons Brienne who looked like they
were really forming a loving
relationship which is heartbreaking for
some reason I'm not buying that he's
gonna really just he's gonna be a bad
guy again all the sudden it doesn't
excuse the fact that he's left Brienne
behind the way he has at the end of the
day I don't see him surviving
whatever he's going to
man's got to do what he's got to do to
you know protect the sister that he
likes the bone these are just facts
these are facts people I kind of took
that thing with Brienne maybe is like
I'm gonna break this off really really
sharply so you don't try to follow me or
anything but I don't know exactly what
Jamie's gonna do because even though I
think he still has a love for Cersei I
don't think he would just go back and
completely fall in with her agenda and
stuff like I feel like even if he does
try to appeal to her or connect to her
somehow it's not just gonna be a full-on
180 back to Jaime I mean but you make a
good point that it is still pretty
jacked up Woody I don't even was trying
to make it because at the end of the
Breanna's loyal to the Stark she would
never have left them because the Starks
are Winterfell the stark or sisters sons
as she would not have left Sansa so I
don't buy that he did it to stop her
from following him he did it to be a
[ __ ] dick speaking of the Starks they
were a great crowd pleasers this episode
you know I don't think crowd pleasers in
the sense they were running their mouths
to the entire crowd hey man what's Game
of Thrones without some gossip right let
me tell the secret to the person who
learns to honestly grates to their
advantage from Littlefinger and Cersei
this episode weirdly I mean some people
will say that they were the third
episode they really felt it a lot but I
think this episode really especially in
its writing showed a lot of the damage
that comes with only having six episodes
to wrap all this up yeah I felt like a
lot of the writing was more expositional
than it has been kind of repetitive you
know like when you pointed out at one
point it's like they had that scene with
Sansa and the Hound talking with each
other which was a cool moment there was
a union it was a neat moment yeah I
don't know what she's talking about but
alright it's like a neat moment then in
the very next scene pretty much saying
the same thing about sunset I'm like we
just heard that scene from what sahn's I
was saying with that a lot of the
dialogue in this I thought wasn't
exactly as subtle as it could have been
and you don't really have the time to
afford the subtlety and in a situation
like this I think that's the biggest
problem here is it really does a
disservice to the fans because even if
they go the mad Queen right within it
which is obvious that's what they're
going to do it's a disservice to the
fans of the characters to wrap it up
into such a short and
manner that they're doing she's not even
there yet and the next episode is
episode 5 I feel like they're trying to
push a lot now they like this episode
for me felt like ok now you're starting
to push things forward without real
build-up to certain elements I feel
there was a surprising death with Rey
gal recall Regis Ronald Reagan sorry
guys I was really guy killed that was
like whoa that did not see that death
coming at all that felt like old Game of
Thrones for half a second yeah big
setback you can't handle animal deaths
thank God you turned away because that
was a brutal death the fact that they
have you're on Greyjoy the most useless
I can't believe he's still alive a
hateable guy character in the entire
show kill a dragon and not someone like
the night king yeah I'll agree with you
on that I do think that it could have
been it could have been a better villain
I'm not bothered by Ron Greyjoy cuz he's
a despicable slime like of course like
being around for just a few episodes
he's not even that great in their
character and or wailings yeah he's an
unlikable character I think this makes
him that much more likable character
he's just nothing but I find him to be a
pretty unlike saboteur up until this
point I feel like he's like one of the
random supporting side villains in the
show and I feel like the death of the
Dragon should have gone to a villain
who's more of a built-up fillable guy
that a night king when he rose and
transformed a dragon that was are you
gonna top that should've gotten he's
gonna kill another we've had the series
I want to take out one of his brothers
we absolutely should be that more than
it being you're on who does it my issue
with the way the death handle was like
Oh shocking in the moment the only
emotional weight that death really had
was when Daenerys says it's something
like they murder much you saw my child
Merv yeah yeah you so much like that's
when I was like oh there's emotional
weight to that death whereas the moment
was just more like whew shocking lack of
the emotional context to that
like oh we needed to get to that line of
dialogue to feel that weight you know
yeah there's not a lot of emotional
impact time for a lot of things and I
think that could have helped again and
again that's I think another just
symptom being crunched because yeah you
get the reacting to the battle for the
first few minutes of this episode and
then we're moving on and we're cramming
everything up until the precipice yeah
the battle for the throne I feel like
this dragon death here was to propel the
threat level of Euron in this scene
let's try to make him more scary or
something like that just set badly it's
just a setback their whole mission I
mean that might be the most significant
thing you're on does in this entire
battle he's probably gonna die in two
seconds that's an extension of what of
Circe's willing to me it's also you're
on did it but it's really Circe's will
that got this all done and her use of
your on that got this all done this is
the demonstration of divided fans right
here and I'm right here in the middle
going on this episode went down
missandei dying oh well that's what I
mean like she gets captured for like a
minute and then a minute later she's
dead it's like it's kind of it's
happening too fast
yeah exactly you're like the second
she's captured then they cut to that
scene you're like oh she's dead you know
it's things like that where I feel like
with more episodes you could have really
let that moment like less episodes that
are longer don't really make up for
having less episodes and situations like
this they know that these people have
these stupid big Spears from the last
season why didn't they put armor on the
dragons or something how how
strategically dumb is the entire I was a
little bit taken aback by those as
shocked as I was by the death and I'm
like Kudo see you guys for pulling off a
surprised ass but the dragon I'll give
the credit for that when they showed
what the distance was between the ships
and the dragons I was like wait you
didn't see that it's either ship you
gotta seem pretty close to where those
ships work
you know that I back kind of took me for
a loop and you're right about that too
like you would probably be a little
prepared for one of the dragons get hit
by a spear last season and was like okay
yeah I mean the major like and that
thing about Euron came in and he was
like I want this special dragon killing
thing didn't they address this I feel
like they made a point at the beginning
of episode two to say that he was an
injured dragon John did say he's injured
I still like there's just so
inconsistent without it the other big
crime of this entire episode is how Jon
Snow treated ghost more than an eye
contact
yeah those dire wolves like insanely
loyal
tormund seems like he knows how to
commune with it and so Stormin like was
that his goodbye like in this moment
where that felt I felt like that was his
like I'll see you again something like
so they kind of imply maybe not I don't
know there was some kind of like cute
little lion that was like oh maybe
they'll come back yeah but awesome yeah
they're just heading back to Castle
black and beyond the wall again that
whole thing with the Starks learning the
secret like that's what I mean there's
no build up to a lot of how this one
goes down it's it's happening so fast I
feel like earlier seasons a game of
Thrones this is not just a compare fest
it's really just a writing issue I would
have had in general with any show
tenaris how this whole thing about don't
tell them John's like I might tell them
they're there then like John's next
scene yeah but it's okay yeah and then
right away sauce is like I'm gonna tell
Siri like right right away it's it's
it's all like it's going so fast and
rather than feeling like a chaotic
tumbling effect that guess that's the
word it doesn't feel effective it feels
more like it's getting kind of rushed
right now it's kind of like Walking Dead
writing a little bit where you kind of
like jump around to a few different
characters then you have like the setup
of something intriguing and then we're
gonna cut away from that and then yeah
not really deal with the meat I feel
like that's kind of what was missing
with this episode specifically there's
things that
like in context there are a lot with
this episode bran showing up I thought
that was a really cool scene the way
that was shot especially I thought was
really neat the way they used the camera
angles in reference to is crossbow I
thought like really amplifying like
there's a crossbow in this room you just
kill him any moment I would really like
the way they shot that specially down
south I've never disagreed with why
Sansa takes issue with Daenerys the Game
of Thrones world has been built up so
well the choices on Sansa's side here I
don't not like Sansa I didn't really
like her in this episode if they like if
there's a way I can really select that
out of what I'm saying I still like
salsa I just didn't like her in this
specific episode it was too much
gossiping they only gave her kind of one
kind of moment to play she's just always
the same look it out I mean that's not
her fault though that's her I did I did
like the scene between her and Tyrion
simply a lot for the way she played that
particular scene Islay I could tell like
oh you guys have anything like huge in
your mind that you're trying to grapple
with what you're talking about that but
that scene goes back to the writing
issue where you're like the way Tyrion
yeah don't being all this sort of like
oh well sauce is clearly gonna take like
it's not a surprise that she's gonna say
it or like yeah oh [ __ ] were you doing
her like okay when's it coming
that's some of the effect that's missing
weirdly I mean I'm some pretty surprised
various is becoming seems like he's
gonna be portraying Daenerys and Tyrion
seems insanely loyal to Daenerys you
know like you see there's no double
crossing on his there's like no hint of
that here who doesn't even want to think
about anything possibly like that oh
yeah well and that's that's been within
at least on the show Varys is character
for a long time I feel like is that
whole like I serve the good of the
people around you know and I love their
conversation back and forth I think you
made a comment you weren't super
thrilled that this is what we're
focusing on in this episode but in in a
weird kind of crunched ending season
where you don't get to have
all the different flavors of Game of
Thrones volt I appreciate those kind of
ideological debates and those are two of
my favorite characters I like their
back-and-forth about that I thought they
drew the struggle of that pretty nicely
for two characters who should be kind of
intellectually I like inaudible I liked
how this episode brought back a lot more
of the political debate one of the
things I loved about the show is its
political debates that they have within
the realm of Game of Thrones it just
seemed like guys you're about to go into
war right now okay you know instead of
thinking about who the next ruler should
be and of Daenerys of like you got no
she's like you're not gonna figure this
out now it's only gonna distract you
from the goal of winning stop even
thinking about this you know and that's
kind of been a thing that's been
happening with this show John tells
Daenerys the truth right before they're
gonna go in a battle I'm like this
shouldn't be on her mind while this is
going on you know she needs to be
focused on the thing at hand
and same thing with the Council of
Daenerys like you guys need to be
focused on what's going on right now
because it's about to get [ __ ]
serious I don't like dislike the show at
all I still like the show to me this was
the weaker one of the four that I've
seen so far in the kind of on the nose
handling a lot of a lot of things I'll
give you that I'll kind of meet you
there it's more just like an enjoyable
episode for me I liked autumn moments
you know yeah and I liked a lot of the
contexts and a lot of the ideas and
stuff like that be I guess I wish the
writing had been a bit more solid you're
not a fan when I go on Facebook in
Twitter now all I see hate towards this
show I know there's always been people
who get like in and debates about this
series and fight over this series iner
I'm very divided now more than ever I'm
like damn all I'm seeing are headlines
of like people pissed off at their show
people being like I don't really write
blogs but I had to write a blog about
why I'm hating this last
letter right now like I'm seeing you how
do you satisfy those expectations yeah
you give it 12 episodes instead of six
in your lfts why yeah yeah I really
can't I'm just flabbergasted at the
chose to take with a lot of their
choices in this episode it's really
disappointing as someone who's read all
the books and followed the show for so
long that I can pretty much already
pinpoint exactly how the rest of the
season is gonna play out for me
personally I'm not gonna know how I feel
about any of this season fully until it
yeah exactly that's where I'm at that's
exactly where I'm at with you is like
I'm waiting to give a whole opinion on
like how I feel about almost every
episode until this whole season is done
because I it really feels like they're
telling you a very specific tale in
these six episodes as much as I like the
way this one ended I'm still like
because she could have still taken out a
lot of those ships there's they just
stared at each other while she's on girl
got like shakarez burn them like you
just did that I cannot wait for her to
slaughter the entire village I'm really
mad quitting I'm like yes kill them all
Danny I want you on the Iron Throne now
I want you to take everyone out I don't
even care at this point you know what go
ahead and burn down everyone else I'm
fascinated by what a mess this has
become I think there have been some
interesting choices made I think there
have been a few clumsy choices made and
I'm curious about next week well what
did you guys think of this episode and
before we wrap this up we owe a patron
of the day and an apology to a woman
named Victoria Huntley you see we have a
shout out reward tier over at our
patreon page going off the information
patreon gives us we try to write down
everyone who is owed a shout-out in one
of our YouTube videos and for some
reason Victoria Huntley's name did not
pop up so when I posted the list of
everyone who got a shout out in the
month of April I got a message from
Victoria who's bit of patient of ours
for many many
saying I didn't get a shout out and then
I lied and said whoopsie really I just
avoided you I did not care in life you
know it was a mistake and I'm sorry I I
really I feel you have no idea like some
people may be like oh my bad I feel
really bad about that so this is your
part one shout out for nay you will get
a second proper shout out person is an
apology second shower will be nothing
but love my dear say hi to your fiance
for me guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell follow Olivia at forever Tiffany's
or she posts constantly about Game of
Thrones not anymore
go check us out on patreon that's where
we got TV show reaction stream along
several reaction highlights included a
weekly Q&A s music video covers love to
have you become a patron chick to J join
us next week